What happened here looks like since you threw a party I've been pretty sick if fire got involved
Go ahead
The dojo is closed to new students today, we just wanted to sign up after we start a tournament
Do I need to say it again? Get out? Yes, sir. Sensei
Let's go. Let's go. Move it come back tomorrow
Bring your checkbooks
Everyone fall in
How's it been a rager sensei yeah, you're celebrating all weekend celebrating what my students are a bunch of pussies
Diaz hawk up front Oh
Did you attack your opponent when his back was turned yes sensei
Diaz did you purposely attack your opponent's injury? Yes sensei
You think that makes you badass
It's a matter too tough a question
Maybe you need some help Miss Robinson. Yes sensei to Cobras in the jungle
one kills the strongest lion
Yeah, that kills a crippled monkey
Which cobra do you want to be the one that kills the lion sensei and why is that because it killed a stronger animal correct?
Cobra Kai is about being badass. And the baddest badass is the one who beats his opponent when he's at his strongest
Not what his back his turn
Not when he's injured
Is that understood yes
That means no more cheating
More fighting dirty
From here on out those are pussy moves and you don't want to be pussies. Do you no good
That's why I had you wear your white belts are starting over
Diaz hawk fifty push-ups on your knuckles Miss Robinson warm them up. Yes, since they
Fighting position jab punch ready? Yeah
Inner peace
Focus
Balance
You can learn the secrets of Okinawan. Karate true karate by joining the Miyagi Doh team because in Miyagi Doh
It's not about the money. It's about the karate
Defeat does not exist in this dojo in for a rude awakening. It's
Cobra Kai is about being badass
Remember it doesn't matter who anyone was before they stepped into this dojo all that matters is that we are all Biaggi, duh
Know how to beat Cobra Kai I did it thirty years ago. I could do it again
Cut great just make sure the Cobra Kai snake comes in at the end or I don't want to really pop
You